So let's try to define a hash function
that has these properties. And what we want the
hash function to do is to take a string
as its input, we'll call the hash function hash_string,
and it'll produce as output a number between 0
and b-1. So, we also need another input to
our hash string, which is going to be the size
of the hash table. So that'll be the second
input is the size of the hash table, the
number of buckets. What we haven't seen yet, that
we're going to need for this function, is a way
to turn a string into a number. Python provides an
operation to do that. It's called ord as an
ordinal, and what ord takes as it's input is
a one letter string and produces as it's output
a number. And actual mapping between strings and numbers is
not so important. We just want something
that is going to map different string to
different numbers. There's another operator that goes in
the opposite direction that takes in a number,
and outputs the one-letter string that corresponds to
that number. And the property these functions have
is their inverses. That if we take the
character corresponding to the ordinal corresponding to any
one-letter string. We'll call that alpha. What we get as a result is the same
alpha that we passed in. So let's try
a few examples in the python interpreter to
see how ord and chr work. So we'll print ord of a, and
when we run that we see we get the number 97. If we try print ord of capital A.
That's different. We get 65. And if we print ord of B,
we get 66. So, the numbers are sort of sensible.
B is higher than A. The lower case letters have
different ordinals than the upper case. So, if we try
a lower case b, we should expect to get 98.
And that is indeed what we get. And these are
the numbers based on the ASCII character encoding, what
the actual numbers are, are not very important for us,
other than that we get different number for different letters.
So we'll be able to use the results
of ord to make different strings hash to different
values. And just to show that there are inverses. If we do ord of u, and
then chart of that, what we get back
is the single letter string u that we started
with. The limit of ord is it only works
on one-letter strings. If it provided a mapping from
any string to a number that would be useful for a
hash table. Well, then we'd be done. But it doesn't do that.
If we try running it on a multi-letter string, we get
an error. It says that ord expects a single character, but it
got a string of length 7. So we're going to need to
use ord only on single letter strings. So with ord, we have
a way of converting strings to numbers. Converting single character strings
to numbers. The other property we need our hash function to have,
is that our output number is always between 0 and B minus 1. We need it to be in
that range, because we're going to use that to index
the list, to find the bucket where that string belongs.